I think it's just one of those things
like people just like to say it they
don't actually care of course saying
like fortnight is like for virgins like
clearly we're not yeah absolutely so
it's yeah it's like one of those types
of theory like we have tons of Zechs
yeah yeah so I mean I've had it for sure
yeah yeah I've definitely had or yeah
I've had sort of yeah but the fine says
[Laughter]
just coming your pants for watching
ninja counts that's the case then I'm a
player yeah I come to myth to cover his
ass after busting that fart farting on
stream it's like like like puts his hand
over his ass all of us oh my god what
are you covering it from stream to smell
my fart stream smells every single part
that's coming out I've never had like
just like a like I bent over and they
like forced it out I've never had that
like he just bent over and like that's
some old people [ __ ] slower myself
[ __ ] up from streaming twenty thousand
hours a week let me just beds over Jay
he's got it like a massively like
herniated disc I mean who covers their
ass after farting what does that do oh
excuse me yeah can you cover your mouth
yeah yeah after you burp I don't you
getting sick
I mean oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
dare I say that was a shaved [ __ ]
fart - oh yeah sure it was clean that
was yeah that was like a waxed no shine
nice so that dude has never grown body
here yeah my yeah my farts are
definitely dampened you know yeah yeah
it feels like a soundproof
they just stink they don't smell that's
why they're so quiet it's just like a
soft base hit okay I guess I guess I
understand the podcast thing now
[Laughter]
defending podcast is talking about I get
it I get it yeah I guess I totally get
it
whatever dude you're you're just selling
people on why they should cancel their
patreon submissions no I'm not keep that
on yeah for God's sake that on cuz
yeah this podcast is [ __ ] it wasn't
for this I I don't know what I'd be
doing yeah you would have found another
programming job I would have had to
there's no way
yeah yeah and then yeah we never would
have bought this mannequin or made our
new fire tunes which I'm actually very
high for that oh dude yeah yeah I think
we found a little rhythm like working in
here and yeah even with all the [ __ ]
around we were still able to track which
was crazy yeah I didn't think we'd be
able to do that Oh even when you're
playing like really yeah yeah I think
it's just cuz I don't know I think on
any like even when they track in like
professional studios they're still bleed
from headphones yeah you just can't hear
it cuz like I don't know the beats over
the beats so loud dude yeah should bang
swords yeah slapper yeah the beats I
make just are so [ __ ] good that like
it doesn't matter yeah Spock has
produced a good number of the new
project she's fine
mmm I did I'm gonna be Phi or John drop
December yeah that's right yeah
hopefully I think we should call it pone
sauce yeah his hair is dyed blue yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
streamer you know the streamer guy yeah
blue hair one of his [ __ ] blue too
you know
Thank You uncle no does the carpet match
the drapes in the back the back room
carpet because if so I would call that a
blue house all right what is this diem
that you sent oh this is the crazy PM I
have ever received no no wait the one
before that which one which one are you
talking about I'm talking about the one
with the requests for how we brand our
podcast yeah that's the one before oh
[ __ ] let me uh let me let me write oh
yeah yeah oh yeah this is great
yeah so I got this diem the other day
hey dude you know there are people on
tumblr tagging pictures of their actual
dicks with hash tag tiny meat gang
completely unidentified it'd have a nice
day like how would we find out for
ourselves
just if we go on tumblr and we're just
like I wonder what the people are saying
on Tom he's probably looking for like
reaction gifts of like you and Cody like
some cool edits yeah yes somebody that
was dope yeah yeah yeah which one I
don't know you got one you're playing
the other day the one they use huh I
love a good edit yeah you know I love a
good at it I could do yeah I think
they're good yeah what someone did was
they put like the Paul Brothers and then
the Dolan twins and there's like a hard
like records cooler young kids and then
mixed in with all the other like that's
cute yes
[Music]
[Music]
these are not